first way we're gonna do it is we're
going to convert both fractions into
improper fractions and then the second
example I'm going to show you another
method so let's jump with a number
method first let's see if we can take a
look at this the first thing I would do
is I would say 6 times 7 is 42 plus 1 is
43 over 6 for this one 10 times 4 is 40
plus 3 is 43 so that's 43 over 10 so now
we have both mixed numbers written as
improper fractions and so what we're
going to do is we're going to find a
common denominator so we want this
denominator to be the same whenever you
add or subtract two fractions so the key
is if you can try to find the smallest
number that 6 goes into evenly and 10
also goes into evenly so in this case we
can see that 6 goes into 30 and 10 goes
into 30 now if you can't find that
number or you're just not so concerned
about finding that number what you can
do is you can just multiply these two
numbers together and just make the
common denominator 6 times 10 60 and
that's fine too but if you can find a
smaller number it's going to make it a
little bit easier so we decided our
common denominator is gonna be 30 okay
because that's the smallest number 6 and
10 both go into to make this tonight
mere 30 I'm gonna have to multiply the
bottom by 5 and then whatever you do to
the denominator you want to do to the
numerator because 5 divided by 5 is
really like 1 so 1 times this fraction
is not going to change its value it's
just going to change the way that it
looks
5 times 43 is actually 215 and over here
we want to make this denominator 30
we're gonna multiply the bottom by 3 but
if we multiply the bottom by 3 we have
to multiply the numerator by 3 again 3
divided by 3 is 1 so it's not going to
change the value of this fraction 3
times 10 is 30 3 times 43 is 129 now if
we subtract we just keep the common
denominator which is going to be 30 but
you take the numerator minus the
numerator so 215 minus 129 is 86 now you
can do that work off to the side if you
want or you could use a calculator so
that's basically it and now all we have
to do is just turn this back into a
mixed number 30 goes into 86 two whole
times with 26 left over so that's 2 and
26 xxx which
and reduce to 1315 so - and 1315 let's
look at this from another perspective
now instead of turning these into
improper fractions let's set this
problem up slightly differently instead
of looking at it horizontally let's look
at it in a vertical fashion like this so
7 + 1 6 - 4 + 3 tents the first thing we
have to do again is we have to get a
common denominator but notice 1/6 and
3/10 these are a little bit smaller than
these large fractions we had over here
so it'll make it a little bit easier to
kind of combine these together so here
again the common denominator is 30 so
I'm going to multiply this bottom one by
3 in the top by 3 I'm going to multiply
the bottom one here by 5 and we're going
to do the bottom one due to the top so
this is really giving us 1 times 5 is 5
6 times 5 is 30 3 times 3 is 9 10 times
3 is 30 but if we take 5 - 9 that's
going to give us a negative number right
so the way we work with this as we say
well let's go ahead and borrow from this
7 so we're going to change a 7 to a 6
we're going to borrow one well when we
add one see we really want this to be
able to combine this with this fraction
here so 1 is really the same thing as 30
over 30 because anything divided by
itself is 1 so now what we really have
here is we have 35 xxx - 9 xxx which is
26 xxx and then 6 minus 4 is just 2 so
you can see we're back to where we were
right here - and 26 xxx all we have to
do is reduce that comes out to 2 + 13 15
s and you've got also great job if
you're new to the channel consider
subscribing I look forward to helping
you in my other math videos where I go
into algebra geometry algebra 2
precalculus a CT math SAT math to help
you raise your grade pass your class
pursue your dreams and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful